Je vais vous parler de la compassion et de la règle d'or
d'un point de vue séculier et même d'un point de vue scientifique.
Je vais tenter de vous donner en quelque sorte une histoire naturelle
de la compassion et de la règle d'or.
Donc, je vais parfois me servir d'un langage assez technique,
et donc ça ne va probablement pas vous sembler aussi chaleureux que
la présentation typique qu'on vous fait sur la compassion.
Je veux vous en avertir.
Donc, je veux bien dire, dès le départ, que je pense, vous voyez, que la compassion c'est merveilleux.
La règle d'or est merveilleuse. Je suis un grand partisan des deux.
Et je pense que c'est merveilleux que les religions du monde,
que les chefs des religions du monde
proclament la compassion et la règle d'or comme principes fondamentaux
faisant partie intégrante de leurs croyances.
En même temps, je pense tout le mérite n'en revient pas aux religions.
Je crois que la nature leur a un peu donné un coup de main ici.
Je vais soutenir l'idée ce soir que la compassion et la règle d'or
sont, en quelque sorte, des parties intégrantes de la nature humaine.
Bon. Mais je vais aussi soutenir
qu'une fois que l'on a compris de quelle façon elles sont parties intégrantes de la nature humaine,
on se rend compte que la simple proclamation de la compassion,
et la proclamation de la règle d'or, ne suffisent pas.
Il reste encore beaucoup de travail après ça.
Bon. Donc, un brève histoire naturelle, d'abord, la compassion.
Au tout début, il y avait la compassion,
et, je veux dire, pas seulement quand les êtres humains sont apparus,
mais en fait même avant ça.
Je pense que c'est sûrement le cas que, dans le lignée évolutive de l'homme,
avant même que les homos sapiens voient le jour,
des sentiments tel que la compassion et l'amour et la sympathie
avaient déjà gagné leur place, en quelque sorte, dans le patrimoine génique,
et les biologistes ont une idée assez claire quant à la façon dont cela s'est passé.
Ça s'est passé par le biais d'un principe connu sous le nom de sélection de parentèle.
Et l'idée principale de la sélection de parentèle est,
si un animal a de la compassion pour un proche parent,
et cette compassion entraîne l'animal à aider son parent,
en fin de compte, la compassion va en fait aider les gènes
qui permettent cette compassion elle-même.
Donc, du point de vue d'un biologiste, la compassion est en fait
la façon que le gène a de s'aider lui-même.
Je vous ai prévenu que ça n'allait pas être très chaleureux.
J'y viens. J’espère devenir un peu plus chaleureux.
Pour moi ce n'est pas -- ça ne me gêne pas plus que ça,
que la logique Darwinien de la compassion
soit un peu égoïste au niveau génétique.
En fait, je pense que la mauvaise nouvelle avec la sélection de parentèle
c'est que cela veut dire que ce genre de compassion
n'est naturellement déployé que dans le contexte familial.
C'est la mauvaise nouvelle. La bonne nouvelle c'est que la compassion est naturelle.
La mauvaise nouvelle c'est que cette compassion sélectionnée par parentèle
se limite naturellement à la famille.
Bon, il y a d'autres bonnes nouvelles qui sont venues plus tard au cours de l'évolution,
une deuxième sorte de logique évolutive.
Les biologistes l'appellent l’altruisme réciproque.
Et là, l'idée de départ est que
la compassion vous entraîne à faire de bonnse choses pour ceux qui ont tendance à rendre la pareille.
Encore une fois, vous savez, je sais, ce n'est pas une conception de la compassion qui inspire autant
que celles dont vous avez entendu parlé par le passé,
mais du point de vue du biologiste, cette compassion émanant de l’altruisme réciproque,
est finalement égoïste aussi.
Ce n'est pas que les gens le pensent quand ils ressentent de la compassion.
Ça n'est pas consciemment égoïste, mais, pour un biologiste, c'est la logique.
Et donc, vous vous retrouvez à étendre votre compassion plus facilement à vos amis et alliés.
Je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous, si quelque chose de terrible arrive a un ami proche,
vous vous sentez très mal.
Mais si vous lisez dans le journal
que quelque chose d'absolument horrible est arrivé à quelqu'un dont vous n'avez jamais entendu parler,
vous savez, votre vie n'en est pas bouleversée. Bon.
C'est tout simplement notre nature humaine.
Donc, c'est encore une histoire de bonne et de mauvaise nouvelles.
C'est bien que la compassion se soit étendue au-delà de la famille
par ce genre de logique évolutive.
La mauvaise nouvelle c'est que cela ne nous apporte pas la compassion universelle en elle-même.
Donc, il reste encore du chemin à faire.
Il reste un autre résultat de cette dynamique appelée altruisme réciproque,
dont je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle,
et c'est que la façon dont cela s'exprime chez l’espèce humaine,
cela permet aux gens d'avoir une sorte d'appréciation intuitive de la règle d'or. Bon.
Je ne veux pas dire par là que la règle d'or elle-même est inscrite dans nos gènes,
mais vous pouvez aller observer une société de chasseurs-cueilleurs
qui n'a jamais été exposée aux grandes traditions religieuses,
aucune exposition à la philosophie éthique,
et vous trouverez, à force de passer du temps avec ces gens,
que, essentiellement, ils adhèrent à l'idée d'un prêté pour un rendu,
et que les mauvaises actions doivent être punies.
Et les psychologues évolutionnistes pensent que ces intuitions ont une origine dans les gènes.
Donc, ils comprennent bien que si l'on veut être bien traité,
il faut bien traiter les autres.
Et c'est bien de bien traiter les autres.
On se rapproche d'une sorte d'intuition innée.
Donc, ça c'est la bonne nouvelle. Donc, si vous avez bien fait attention,
vous êtes sûrement en train d'anticiper la mauvaise nouvelle ici,
que nous n'en sommes toujours pas à l'amour universel,
et c'est vrai parce que, bien qu'une appréciation de la règle d'or soit naturelle,
il est aussi naturel d'établir quelques exceptions à la règle d'or.
Je veux dire par cela, par exemple, qu'aucun d'entre nous, probablement, ne veut aller en prison,
mais nous pensons tous qu'il existe certaines personnes qui devraient aller en prison. N'est-ce pas?
Donc, nous pensons que nous devrions les traiter différemment de la façon dont nous voudrions être traités.
Bon, nous avons une logique pour cela.
On dit qu'ils ont fait du mal, ce qui rend leur emprisonnement juste.
Aucun d'entre nous n'étend la règle d'or de façon véritablement diffuse et universelle.
Nous avons la capacité d'établir quelques exceptions,
de mettre des gens dans une catégorie spéciale.
Et le problème est que, bien que dans le cas de l'emprisonnement,
il existe une justice impartiale
qui détermine, vous voyez, qui se fait exclure de la règle d'or,
dans la vie de tous les jours, la façon que nous avons tous de décider
à qui nous n'étendrons pas la règle d'or,
nous utilisons une formule plus brute et plus directe,
et en gros c'est comme, si vous êtes mon ennemi, si vous êtes mon rival,
si vous n’êtes pas mon ami, si vous n’êtes pas de ma famille,
je suis d'autant moins enclin à vous appliquer la règle d'or. Bon.
On le fait tous d'une certaine façon,
et on peut l'observer tout autour du monde.
Par exemple, vous le voyez au Moyen-Orient.
Les gens qui, de Gaza, tirent des missiles sur Israël.
Ils ne voudraient pas que l'on tire des missiles sur eux, mais ils disent,
"Oui, mais les Israéliens, ou certains d'entre eux ont commis des actes
qui les mettent dans une catégorie spéciale."
Les Israéliens ne voudraient pas qu'on leur impose un blocus économique,
mais ils en imposent un sur Gaza, et ils disent,
"Oui, mais les Palestiniens, ou certains d'entre eux, l'ont bien cherché."
Donc, ce sont ces exclusions à la règle d'or qui sont responsables de beaucoup des maux planétaires.
Et c'est naturel de faire ça.
Donc, le fait que la règle d'or fasse dans un sens partie de nous
ça ne va pas, tout seul, nous apporter l'amour universel.
Ça ne va pas sauver le monde
Bien, il me reste quand même une bonne nouvelle qui puisse sauver le monde.
Êtes-vous bien accrochés à vos sièges, là?
Bien, parce qu'avant que je vous parle de cette bonne nouvelle,
je vais devoir faire m'engager un peu sur le terrain théorique.
Donc, j’espère avoir capturé votre attention avec cette promesse de bonne nouvelle
qui pourrait sauver le monde.
C'est cette affaire de jeu à somme non-nulle dont on vient de vous parler un peu.
C'est une introduction rapide à la théorie des jeux.
Ça ne vous fera pas de mal.
Il s'agit des jeux à somme nulle et à somme non-nulle.
Si vous demandez quelle genre de situation
génère des amitiés et des alliances entre personnes,
la réponse technique est une situation à somme non-nulle.
Et si vous demandez quel genre de situation
pousse les gens à définir certaines personnes comme ennemis,
c'est en quelque sorte une situation à somme nulle.
Donc, que veulent dire ces termes?
En bref, un jeu à somme nulle, c'est ce que l'on trouve habituellement en sport,
où il y a un gagnant et un perdant.
Donc, la somme de leurs chances est zéro.
Donc, au tennis, chaque point est soit positif pour vous et négatif pour l'autre,
soit positif pour lui, négatif pour vous.
Dans les deux cas, la somme de vos chance est zéro. C'est ce qu'on appelle un jeu a somme nulle.
Maintenant, si vous jouez en double,
la personne de votre côté du filet
a un rapport à somme non-nulle avec vous,
parce que chaque point est soit positif pour vous deux, positif, gagnant-gagnant,
ou négatif pour vous deux, c'est perdant-perdant. Ok.
C'est un jeu à somme non-nulle.
Et dans la vie de tous les jours, il y a beaucoup de jeux à somme non-nulle.
Dans le domaine de l'économie, disons, si vous achetez quelque chose,
cela veut dire que vous préférez avoir la marchandise plutôt que l'argent,
mais le marchant préfère avoir l'argent plutôt que la marchandise.
Vous avez tous les deux l'impression d'avoir gagné.
Dans une guerre, deux alliés jouent un jeu à somme non-nulle.
Ça va se finir en gagnant-gagnant ou en perdant-perdant pour eux.
Donc, il existe beaucoup de jeux à somme non-nulle dans la vie de tous les jours.
Et vous pourriez en gros reformuler ce que j'ai dit plus tôt,
sur comment la compassion se déploie et la règle d'or se déploie,
juste en disant, eh bien, la compassion circule le plus naturellement par des canaux à somme non-nulle
où les gens se perçoivent comme étant dans une situation potentiellement gagnante-gagnante
avec certains de leurs amis et alliés.
Le déploiement de la règle d'or
a lieu le plus naturellement par le biais de ces canaux à somme non-nulle.
Donc, des sortes de réseaux à somme non-nulle,
sont ceux où l'on s'attend à ce que la compassion et la règle d'or
fassent des miracles.
Avec des canaux à somme nulle on s'attend à autre chose..
Bon. Donc, vous êtes fins prêts pour la bonne nouvelle dont j'ai dit qu'elle pourrait sauver le monde.
Et maintenant je peux admettre qu'elle pourrait très bien ne pas le sauver,
maintenant que j'ai réussi à garder votre attention pendant trois minutes de détails techniques.
Mais elle le pourrait. Et la bonne nouvelle est que l'histoire
a naturellement étendu ces réseaux à somme non-nulle,
ces réseaux qui peuvent être les véhicules de la compassion.
On peut remonter aussi loin que l’âge de pierre,
et, il me semble, de l'évolution des technologies, des routes, la roue, l'écriture,
beaucoup de technologies de transport et de communication
ont inexorablement permis à plus de gens
d'être de plus en plus dans des relations à somme non-nulle
avec de plus en plus de gens sur des distances de plus en plus grandes.
C'est un peu l'histoire de la civilisation.
C'est pourquoi l'organisation sociale a évolué du village des chasseusr-cueilleurs
à l'état ancien, à l'empire, à présent ici nous sommes dans un monde globalisé.
Et l'histoire de la mondialisation est largement une histoire de somme non-nulle.
Bon. Vous avez sûrement entendu le terme interdépendance
appliqué au monde moderne. Eh bien, c'est simplement un autre terme pour une somme non-nulle.
Si vos destins sont interdépendants avec quelqu'un d'autre,
c'est que vous avez un rapport à somme non-nulle avec lui.
Et c'est ce que l'on observe tout le temps dans le monde moderne.
Vous en avez été témoin récemment avec le krach boursier,
qui a eu des impacts négatifs sur l'économie,
négatisf pour tout le monde, pour une bonne partie de la planète.
Si des choses positives ont lieu, une grande partie du monde en bénéficie.
Et, vous voyez, je suis heureux de pouvoir dire, je pense qu'il existe bel et bien des preuves
que ce genre de lien à somme non-nulle
peut étendre le sens moral.
Par là je veux dire, si vous regardez l'attitude américaine
envers les Japonais, durant la deuxième guerre mondiale,
regardez la façon dont on représente les japonais,
dans les médias Américains, comme étant à peine humain,
et remarquez le fait qu'on ait lâchédes bombes atomiques,
sans trop y réfléchir vraiment.
Et vous comparez ça à notre attitude actuelle,
je pense que d'une certaine façon c'est dû à une sorte d'interdépendance économique.
Toute forme d'interdépendance, de relation à somme non-nulle
nous force à reconnaître l'humanité des gens.
Donc, je pense que c'est une bonne chose.
Et le monde est plein de dynamiques à somme non-nulle.
Les problèmes environnementaux, à bien des égards, nous mettent tous dans le même bateau.
Et il existe des relations à somme non-nulle dont nous ne sommes peut-être pas conscient.
Bien, donc, par exemple, probablement beaucoup de chrétiens américains
ne se voient pas comme étant dans une relation à somme non-nulle
avec les musulmans à l'autre bout du monde,
mais en fait ils le sont parce que si ces musulmans deviennent de plus en plus heureux
quant à leur place dans le monde et sentent qu'ils y ont leur place,
c'est bien pour l'Amérique parce qu'il y aura moins de terroristes
mettant en péril la sécurité américaine.
S'ils deviennent de moins en moins heureux, ça ne sera pas bon pour les Américains.
Donc, il y a pas mal de somme non-nulle.
Et donc, la question est: S'il y a tellement de somme non-nulle,
pourquoi le monde n'a-t-il pas encore été imprégné d'amour, de paix, et de compréhension?
La réponse est compliquée. C'est peut-être un sujet pour une autre présentation,
mais on peut être certain de deux choses :
tout d'abord, il y a beacoup de situations à somme nulle dans le monde.
Et aussi, vous voyez, parfois, encore, les gens ne reconnaissent pas
les dynamiques à somme non-nulle dans le monde.
Et je pense, que dans ces deux domaines,
je pense que les politiciens peuvent jouer un rôle.
Il ne s'agit pas que de religion.
Je pense que les politiciens peuvent encourager des relations à somme non-nulle,
vous voyez, les engagements économiques sont généralement meilleurs que les blocus et ainsi de suite,
je crois, à cet égard.
Et les politiciens peuvent être conscients, et doivent être conscients.
que quand les gens dans le monde entier les regardent,
regardent leur nation,
et réagissent à leurs propos
selon qu'ils se trouvent dans une relation à somme non-nulle ou nulle avec une nation.
comme, disons, l'Amérique, ou n'importe quelle autre nation,
la psychologie humaine est telle qu'ils se servent de repères tel que:
Est-ce qu'on se sent respecté?
Parce que, vous savez, historiquement, si vous n’êtes pas respectés,
vous n'allez probablement pas finir dans une situation à somme non-nulle,
une relation mutuellement bénéfique avec les gens.
Donc, il nous faut être conscients du genre d'image que nous véhiculons.
Et une partie de cela, encore une fois, réside plus ou moins dans le domaine du travail politique.
S'il y a une chose que je peux encourager tout le monde à faire,
les politiciens, les chefs religieux, et nous-mêmes,
se serait de développer ce que j’appelle l'imagination morale.
C'est-à-dire votre capacité à vous mettre dans la peau
de personnes dans des circonstances très différentes des vôtres.
Ce n'est pas la même chose que la compassion,
mais ça entraîne la compassion. Ça permet de mieux véhiculer la compassion.
Et j'ai bien peur qu'ici, nous ayons une autre histoire de bonne et mauvaise nouvelle,
qui est que l'imagination morale fait partie de la nature humaine.
C'est bien, mais encore une fois on a tendance à la déployer sélectivement.
Une fois que l'on définit quelqu'un en tant qu'ennemi,
on a du mal à se mettre dans sa peau, c'est naturel..
Donc, si vous voulez prendre un cas particulier difficile, disons pour un américain,
quelqu'un en Iran, qui brûle un drapeau américain disons, et vous le voyez à la télé.
Eh bien, l’américain moyen va résister à
l’exercice moral qui consiste à se mettre dans la tête de cette personne
et va résister à l'idée que cette personne et lui ont en fait beaucoup en commun.
Et si vous lui dites, eh bien, ils pensent que l'Amérique ne les respectent pas
et veut même les dominer, et ils détestent l'Amérique.
N'y a-t-il jamais eu quelqu'un qui vous manquait tellement le respect
que vous l'avez en quelque sorte détesté brièvement?
Vous savez, ils résisteront à cette comparaison et c'est naturel, c'est humain.
Et, de façon similaire, la personne en Iran,
quand vous essayez d'humaniser quelqu'un en Amérique qui dit que l'Islam c'est le mal.
vous allez avoir du mal.
Donc, c'est très difficile de faire en sorte que les gens étendent leur imagination morale
là où elle ne va pas naturellement.
Je crois que ça vaut le peine parce que,
encore une fois, ça nous aide a comprendre,
si vous voulez réduire le nombre de personnes qui brûlent des drapeaux,
ça aide de savoir ce qui les poussent à le faire.
Et je crois que c'est un bon exercice moral.
Je dirais que là encore les chefs religieux ont leur rôle,
parce que les chefs religieux arrivent bien à recadrer des situations pour les gens, vous savez,
à exploiter les centres émotionnels du cerveau
pour faire en sorte que les gens modifient leur conscience et recadrent tout simplement leur façon de penser, vous voyez.
Je veux dire par là que l'inspiration est l'affaire des chefs religieux.
C'est leur grande vocation en ce moment,
de faire en sorte que les gens tout autour du monde puissent mieux développer leur imagination morale,
pour apprécier qu'à bien des égards, ils sont tous dans le même bateau.
Je voudrais juste résumer la façon dont se présentent les choses, du moins d'un point de vue séculier,
pour ce qui est de la compassion et de la règle d'or,
en disant que c'est une bonne nouvelle que la compassion et la règle d'or
soient d'une certaine façon partie intégrante de la nature humaine.
C'est dommage qu'on ait tendance à les déployer sélectivement.
Et il va nous falloir beaucoup de travail pour changer ça.
Mais, personne n'a jamais dit que faire le boulot de Dieu allait être facile. Merci.
(Applaudissements)